hello there today i'm interviewing
patrick minow who has a phd from mcgill
and did a postdoc at ucla he's an
independent scientist and a neural data
scientist his interests are neuroscience
and the connection to machine learning
he has an awesome blog called x-core
which i guess is pronounced
cross-correlation but who knows so
please check out patrick's blog he also
worked at google for a while seeing how
people interact with web pages and was a
brain computer interface engineer at
facebook reality labs he also has
launched the neuro match academy which
is sort of an intro and academy where
you learn in a summer school about
computational neuroscience this runs
every year and you can take part if you
want we're going to touch on that a
little bit in the interview i just
wanted to take it away beforehand so i'm
going to give a little introduction
about what we'll talk about and then
we'll jump into the interview
we're going to talk about mainly about
this blog post right here the 2021 in
review unsupervised brain model the main
focus here is on unsupervised models and
how what they have to do with the brain
so a big question in neuroscience is how
does the brain work i guess it's the
main question in neuroscience and so
people are developing the hypothesis
like hypotheses of how the brain works
and deep learning turns out to be quite
a interesting tool for neuroscientists
because in deep learning we get some
inspiration from neuroscience but
essentially we build model that end to
end can learn some tasks to perform some
tasks so this would be this one right
here now the question is is what deep
models do the same or different than
what brains do given that they solve the
same task like let's say both recognize
objects on images do they do the same
thing or do they do something completely
different so neuroscientists they wonder
you know how does the brain learn stuff
is it the same as neural network does
the neural net work now also during the
interview i have to stop saying neural
network because it's ambiguous in this
context so does a deep network a
computer a human-made deep network does
it account for neural activity which
means that are the signals in the deep
network the same or related to the
signals that we see in the brain and
this turns out to be a very important
tool for neuroscientists what they want
to see is that let's say the
intermediate representations in the
neural network like you have some kind
of picture it goes into a neural network
there's layer layer layer layer and then
there's a classification head the
classification head might not be that
interesting but what is interesting is
like some intermediate representation
here if we figure out that that explains
which means we can correlate it with
things that are in the brain and i'm
going to draw like a very bad brain
right here
if we can correlate this with things
that are found in the brain signals like
from fmri from electrodes that we put
into people's heads then that is an
indication that what these deep networks
are doing have
something like that there isn't an
effect that is similar and that could
help us understand the brain so the holy
grail by in neuroscience would be
something that can perform the same task
as humans that does account for neural
neural activity that is biologically
plausible as you might know there is
still a debate of whether something like
backprop is implementable in the brain
in one way or another or if we need an
entirely different mechanism in the
brain and lastly something that could
conceivably also have evolved and maybe
we'd even have some evidence of how it
evolved over time so we're going to talk
about
these models right here specifically
self-supervised models self-supervised
models here is a slide by yon le con are
models that don't need labels to train
and what you usually do is you block out
part of something you know and then try
to predict that from the parts that you
do know for example if it is an image
again you'd block out some part of the
image and then from the rest of the
image you'd try to predict that part
that is a self-supervised method there's
also contrastive methods which are
self-supervised which means that you'd
have an image
and
you make two different views of it for
example by cropping the image in
different places and then you try to
train a model that can tell that these
two things actually belong together come
from the same image and that they are
apart from i'm gonna draw inverted
arrows right here they they are apart
from like a third image that has nothing
to do with this image these are
contrastive methods it turns out that if
we build models that learn in
self-supervised in contrasting ways and
especially in multi-modal ways that we
end up with models that can explain
brain activity fairly well
so we're going to jump into the papers
right here in the interview pretty
quickly but if you keep watching the
interview patrick goes also into more
like high level explanations of
neuroscience in general it is a bit my
fault that i immediately it was like so
what does this paper say but i promise
you if you keep listening throughout the
interview there are great insights into
the entire field of neuroscience into
what are open questions into where can
people go to uh where can people go to
to to learn about this and uh if you
even want to research this if you're in
deep learning right now and you're
interested in neuroscience this patrick
says it's a wide open field there's lots
of papers to be published and the
conferences are especially something
like new reps are pretty receptive to
papers that connect deep learning with
neuroscience
or in general try to explain
neuroscience uh neuroscience things so
as i said we're going to jump into the
interview now i don't want to spend too
much more time because we're very
detailed in the interview check out
patrick's blog and all his other
endeavors and i wish you a lot of fun
bye
[Music]
hello everyone today here with me i have
patrick mino who is a neuroscientist
uh slash blogger slash anything else
that you might imagine in between deep
learning and the human brain uh welcome
patrick to the channel for this bit of a
special episode i guess
thanks uh it's great to be here
i got i got um sort of knowledge of you
for through your article uh 2021 in
review unsupervised brain models you
wrote down what happened in the last
year in terms of the connection of deep
learning and uh how to let's say how to
explain the brain what is your what is
your background in this area how did you
come to be
in this in-between space between
neuroscience and a.i yeah absolutely um
so i actually originally studied physics
and uh you know after my undergrad i
figured
you know maybe i don't want to do string
theory for the rest of my life like that
sounds it sounds like some of the
questions that uh
to ask like interesting questions uh you
need to really be pretty advanced but i
think in neuroscience there's some
questions that are pretty right for the
picking and that are obvious for even
somebody that's
pretty far outside the field so for
instance uh what is sleep what does it
do
that's like a pretty easy question
that's that's very hard to answer
um so i went to do a phd in
computational neuroscience uh at mcgill
and
one of the fields of my study was really
that intersection of neuroscience um and
artificial intelligence now when i
started my phd which was in 2008 deep
learning really wasn't a thing i guess
like some of the original papers by uh
benjio
and jeffrey hinton had been
they were out but you know the big event
i think in in
uh presenting deep learning to the world
and saying like this is really is this
is a big deal was imagenet
right um as you know so that was during
my phd so at the the very start of my uh
um
of my phd presentation my phd defense i
would say something like look you know
you have neurons in infra temporal
cortex which is one part of the visual
stream and they're able to do visual
recognition
uh that would present examples of these
neurons and their invariant
and
things like lighting rotation scale etc
we don't know how to make a computer
that does that but if i gave this
presentation just you know six months or
a year later i would never have been
able to say that because people have
been like
uh you know you can just you know like
get even alex that would uh would be
able to do that
um so uh so that's a little bit uh my
my story my introduction to uh to neuro
ai so i was there like
during that transition
towards deep learning and in fact in the
at the end of my phd i was uh i was
working on
uh deep learning to try and explain some
of the brain areas that i cared about
now these brain areas uh are the areas
of the dorsal stream and those are like
really brain areas that really care
about motion
and so i was poking around with what was
uh
i'm gonna date myself you know i was uh
poking around in thiano uh back in the
day to uh to make this happen
uh which i guess has
fallen by the wayside um but uh yeah so
i've been at this intersection for uh
quite a while now
awesome well that it seems like it was
an exciting time i do remember theano as
well so i'm definitely dated dated the
same um
so you the dorsal stream just to make
clear that's part of sort of the visual
the visual stream uh into the brain is
that correct or yeah yeah so maybe i can
uh i can give you like the first minute
of my uh my thesis defense
because i've got it uh engraved in my
brain you just uh
you defended not too too long ago right
true
exactly i'm sure you're gonna forgot it
i found oh yeah yeah you just like put
it in the box in your brain and just
it's gone okay
um so
the visual information falls on the
retina uh and it's originally encoded in
these very simple formats in terms of
differences and luminance between like a
center and a surround or differences in
time
um so you can think of it as
a camera with like a little bit of
linear filtering
and uh it then gets forwarded to uh
different areas of the brain first to
the lateral geniculate nucleus and then
to the back of the brain the occipital
cortex which is called the primary
visual cortex so that's a huge area a
huge chunk of the brain and you have
tons of
neurons which are selective for vision
there
and from uh
from there the
visual processing splits into
two different substreams there's the
ventral visual stream which is the
object stream
um so if you think like what does a
you know resnet50 that strain on on
imagenet do
maybe it's something similar that we can
get into that later
and uh then there's another set of areas
which is the dorsal stream um again
organized in a hierarchical fashion
again you have like these uh
you know
for instance you have increases in the
size of receptive fields you have
increases in the size of in the
complexity of things that these neurons
respond to but this time they don't care
about form they don't care whether they
don't care about texture
what they really care about is motion
uh so
you know you're going to poke at
a neuron in let's say the middle
temporal area which is part of the
dorsal stream and 80 or 90 of the
neurons will respond when you show him
the right moving stimulus yeah which is
which is uh remarkable
so in your in your article you go a
little bit into both of these uh streams
and i think the one of the main focuses
that you care about is
are or are the are or are not the deep
learning networks we use today
similar to what the brain does because
sure we've built these systems that can
do some visual tasks but does that bring
us closer to
understanding how the brain does certain
things and the answer is right the
answer is a little bit yes and a little
bit
no like there's still there's still
questions but you point out a bunch of
areas of where progress has been made in
uh correlating let's say neural
activities in deep neural networks with
neural activities in in brains so
yeah yeah uh i'm i think that uh it
might be good to just back up a little
bit and talk about the uh you know that
world at large so that yeah you know
people are just tuning in i haven't read
the article yet will
um
uh understand what uh we're discussing
uh i think that originally
you know some some of the um
um
okay so i was talking about imagenet
2012 which was the uh the big milestone
and creating good deep neural networks
that could solve the kinds of tests that
humans that humans can solve
now there was a lot of background work
uh that came into that uh one is you
know the creation of convolutional
neural networks and the word from uh
from yandere kun which was ultimately
you know inspired by the new the the
neocognitron which is uh fukushima like
around the the early 80s
but ultimately that work was motivated a
lot by some early work in
vision and envision neuroscience
so david yuble and torsten weasel in the
50s and 60s
looked at different kinds of neurons in
the primary visual cortex and were able
to find that you have this this
hierarchy of
of um selectivity right so the canonical
thing that they found is
they
found cells which were tuned for
orientation right so
you know you present
a an edge like this or a line like this
and the cell responds but if the line if
instead of being white it's black then
it doesn't respond so those are called
the simple cells and then they found
another subset of cells which are called
the complex cells and so those are
selective for this but they would be uh
it wouldn't matter the the precise
location
of this line in question and it wouldn't
matter the the contrast so it could be
white to black or it could be black to
white
it wouldn't matter
and so their hunch was that okay well
you have this this transformation that
happens first of all you have a
selectivity operation which creates that
simple cell
so basically just a threshold and that's
enough to give you a activity or it
could be a rally if you
you know smooth it out
and um and then there's a pooling
operation
that that happens so you pull from
different uh from different simple cells
that have the same orientation sectivity
but different contrast sensitivity
and that creates the complex cell and
you can view that as a sub-sampling
operation or down-sampling operation as
you would have in a deep neural net so
there's this kind of long line of like
oh there's the inspiration from the
brain
we're going to make some models we're
going to show that it's that they're
actually good enough to solve tasks that
humans can solve but the question is
okay are these are these like really
like like human brains
um so uh and that's uh some of the work
from um
uh from
in jimmy carlo's lab and uh nico creek
escort in 2014 like really showed that
there's some very tantalizing hints that
this is indeed the case you know that
these networks that we've trained on
imagenet they look a lot like the brain
in
um in really interesting ways and one of
the big ways that uh
you know they're similar is that
uh if you have if you look at you know
let's say 10 different
networks
and
uh one of them is
some of them turned out to be a little
bit better at solving imagenet uh or a
little bit worse and then you correlate
that with how well you can
align these networks to the brain it
turns out that the ones which perform
better on imagenet tend to also perform
better on explaining the brain which is
like a very strange coincidence because
think about how like completely
different
these two things have
been created
um so that was that was one of the big
hints and i i think like another big
hint is the word from chris ola and
other people at openai
that looked inside of these deep neural
networks and found that you know the
kinds of selectivity that you see inside
the cells they're very very similar to
what you would what a neurophysiologist
would describe in areas like v1 v2 v4
infra temporal cortex
so the combination of the quantitative
and qualitative tells us like hey maybe
maybe there's a kind of these are kind
of like little brains yes
one very very specific part of the brain
i i want to be get into a lot of trouble
if you say that that statement yes
exactly exactly so what do people mean
when they say something like explains
the brain or something aligns with brain
activity like what what is it what is
behind that
yeah yeah yeah so we can talk about the
the high level stuff like sure just like
the idea of look how like what what do
we what do we measure like
you know is it a number is it a
correlation or is it am i training a
regression model from one signal to the
other signal like how how can i make the
statement that's obvious oh yeah this
neural network explains some function in
the brain
so in the early work from uh from 2014
uh
we see two different approaches being
used and those are the kinds of
approaches like every other approach
that's been tried uh is kind of a
derivative of these like two basic
concepts
so one approach is a regression based
approach so
let's so um very simply let's say you
train a resnet 50 on
on imagenet
you chop it off at
some layer layer four after the first
down sampling or whatever
and then you measure the output of that
deep neural network
with respect to some stimulus ensemble
so which gives you a big matrix big x uh
which has a bunch of rows for the
different examples and a bunch of of
columns for the different features
and then you just regress that
against neural data that's uh that's
recorded with the same
um with the same images and yes
so it's just a regression so you can add
like a bunch of
different spices into your your basic
recipe so you can uh add some some
sparseness priors you can
uh try to well usually you'll use a
ridge regression rather than a straight
regression because that will
definitely yeah the the regular
regression will
usually crash and burn neural data is
very noisy that's something that people
don't often appreciate
um
and so it's a regression let's just put
it that way now that would be sort of
for example fmri data when we talk about
neural data
um
it can be fmri data it can be um
meg data so uh
magneto and
encephalophograph
i think
we just say amigi
um
or it could be a single neuron
recordings or array recordings so those
are taken inside the brain or mighty cog
which is just on the surface of the
brain so there's different kinds of uh
of recordings now it happens that
uh fmri and mg are much more popular
for for humans because it's it's it's
non-invasive but every once in a while
people get to record inside of the
brains of humans that have some uh some
sort of
need for brain surgery whether it's
usually it's epilepsy
and those data are very precious
now speaking of so you go through
different
papers in your article
so maybe we we can follow that structure
a little bit the first one is a work
that
shows that the ventral stream uh might
be explainable
by
and your your idea
your the article also goes into it's
called unsupervised um unsupervised
brain models so you're you're
kind of point that you make is or your
investigation is into unsupervised
systems like
what yeah what
how good or how close to what the brain
does is comes from these self-supervised
and unsupervised system so the first um
the first
the first thing you go into is the
ventral sorry the ventral stream that is
you set the sort of object stream
and yeah and this paper looks at single
neuron activations right
and the they find that the
self-supervised systems can be or are
equally or even better
able to explain
the brain data than supervised systems
let's say in an image recognition task
yeah so that's super exciting and the
reason is that i i think that everybody
got very excited when they saw that
these networks which were trained for
imagenet they could be aligned for to
the ventral stream
uh to that object recognition stream
because now it's something that you know
you have this in silico thing and it
kind of looks like it does the same
thing as the brain and so it's kind of a
model of the brain super exciting you
can do a lot of things with it
um but there's different ways in which
something can be a model of of of the
brain and some of these are a little bit
more useful than others and and one of
the ways i one of the big flaws i think
for uh
for supervised learning
is that it's not like really a way it's
not really a model of how the brain
would learn a task because you know i'm
not walking around as a baby and like
you know my uh my parent just tells me
like dog dog dog dog dog
cat
dog
just like constantly for years and years
um so you know we don't really use
unsupervised learning uh
for uh for for learning these kinds of
uh of things so that's a big flaw that
um
if we want to go and move forward with
models which are biologically plausible
uh instantiations of of creating these
uh these models then we have to move
away from uh from supervised learning
so people generally like unsupervised
learning and self-supervised learning
better for that reason because you don't
have to
you know come up with this like
weird concept that
you have dog dog dog cat
and and but you do have to do the math
to make sure that
it actually does work out in practice
and that you know the right the kinds of
the the quantity of examples that you
feed into
uh into the model is similar to the
kinds of to the quantity of examples
that you would feed into a human for
instance i think you have you have a so
in your conclusion you have a little bit
of an example that uh it would like the
language models that we train such as
gpt3 would be equivalent to like
years and years and years of of human
just constants just
talking and talking babies are able to
do it by age what four or so or two
yeah
yeah exactly so uh so i think that
there's still a uh
a big gap there that comes from that you
still i mean we're off i think i
calculated that we're off by four orders
of magnitude in terms of the efficiency
um but
you know i'm uh to to score everybody on
the same kind of curve i mean the gpt3
is not made as a model of the brain i
mean it's made as a language model and
to solve all these these problems in
zero shot settings and it works very
well for
for its purposes um but uh definitely if
we want to actually try to explain the
brain we'll need to get to that and so
this this
the
it is also a bit special because we hear
we talk about the ventral stream you
said that's the object stream and the
fact that self-supervised systems are
equal or better at explaining that than
supervised systems which presumably are
trained exactly on the task
of that such an object stream would be
sensitive too right that is also one
special thing
so i totally agree i mean that's super
cool that that this is the case that you
have this uh
this thing where you don't give it like
learn objects and yet it learns
something that can do object recognition
uh and it learns meaningful uh
meaningful things like that but i think
that there's a couple of of hidden
assumptions there that make this not
nearly as mysterious as it was like as
we would like it to be so one is that
you know imagenet is not really
if your your model of
imagenet is not you take like a like a
nice canon the
dlsr
and uh you know you
you put it at a random point in space
and then uh you point it at somewhere
random and then you hit the the button
right so uh if we look at both of our
faces right now we're in the center of
the screen it turns out that uh you know
we're smart like that that we place our
faces like generally in the center of
the screen when we take photos so the
things that we try to look at
in imagenet
you know the subject of the the category
will by and large be in the center
um so uh and you know the position of
the camera the things that we uh that we
tend to to measure i mean these are all
these all come into why the model learns
the thing that it learns
um so it's not
we can't really say oh uh it uh
you know we're not like really feeding
in any uh any structural priors we
definitely do we definitely do just just
in not like the the conventional way and
not in a way that's very easy to
quantify either
but some people are definitely trying to
solve these uh
these problems so um sophie for instance
there's a lot of work on
um
trying to fit the same kinds of
unsupervised learning models but with
streams of data that look more like what
a baby would would see in
their early years uh within which the
camera is not always pointed at at the
right things uh because babies tend to i
see yeah yeah yeah do a lot of gestures
but it's also it's all also there it's
special because the baby with time is
able to move its head right and and
therefore it's also not the same as just
placing a camera somewhere because
whatever captures attention will be
actively looked at more so it's it's
definitely like i think there's a long
way to go
in any of these things oh yeah oh yeah
absolutely i i think uh um so to close
the uh
just that that one paper because we've
been on it for
like 15 minutes but super cool that
you can have uh you can train a model in
an unsupervised or self-supervised
manner and it turns out to be just as
good at explaining you know v1 v4 and
idt all these different sub areas of the
ventral stream and then there's a kind
of hierarchy that happens between the uh
the different um
the different models so you know some
models are clearly uh doing better than
others so typically in these peoples uh
in these papers simclear is usually the
one that performs the best for reasons
that we don't totally understand
local aggregation also uh tends to uh to
do better so that's
interesting like what is it about what's
inside of these models that can that
allows them to be more similar to the
brain now of course in the end you know
you end up with like tiny tiny error
bars
and uh it can be pretty difficult to
actually differentiate between these uh
these different things so you know you
can't like read too too much into it uh
but definitely the best models are like
the new kind of generation of
self-supervised models and then so the
next paper deals with the with the with
the other stream with the dorsal stream
and there you are yes that is actually
you who found some that's your own paper
right oh yeah so uh so i'll just go very
rapidly with uh through the actually the
second one is uh ventral stream oh sorry
uh again and so that's uh from talia
concoll
and very very uh consistent uh data so
they use fmri rather than single neuron
data but i mean the data is
like these uh two studies were done
independently uh about a kilometer away
from each other one one team from
harvard and one team from mit and they
found exactly the same results so maybe
something's in the water in cambridge
massachusetts
but otherwise i mean it's a very robust
finding basically
uh but uh yeah we can definitely talk
about the dorsal stream so
like i said i've been interested in this
problem for a uh uh for a very long time
and i had a little bit of time during
the uh the the last lockdown of the
pandemic to
to re-look at this problem and so we sat
down and said you know this i think like
the time is right to really
uh look at all this dorsal stream data
and see if we can k if we can get one
really good
model of all these uh these different
areas
so the first thing that i did actually
is um i was going about this very
naively but i just looked into like the
torch vision models
you know they have like some some model
database and just downloaded all the
models that were trained on
um
video recognition
uh so all the models that were trained
on um
uh
i i'm drawing a blank here kinetics 400
which is a task where you have to look
at a video of somebody juggling and say
oh it's juggling rather than unicycling
rather than soccer or whatever
and
so the special thing about these models
that they look at 3d data uh by 3d i
mean spatial temporal right in time and
so that means that
and and generally they're trained um the
convolutional neural nets they're
trained with 3d filters uh so you know
the
the front end of the model is going to
be a 3d convolution
in space and time
and so i looked at these models and i
did uh the kinds of visualization tricks
that chrysolla and uh and gang do at uh
at open ai to look inside because i was
curious you know do they learn motion do
they align with with the brain and i
found that they were actually like
really terrible
which surprised me because uh if you
look into the methods of these papers
it's like we trained
uh
we train these models for 24 hours on a
supercomputer with uh you know 16 gpus
in parallel
and uh went through you know a million
videos and this is the model that that
we obtain and they're very good at doing
the tests that they're doing and yet the
kinds of generic features that come out
of the models are
really terrible at aligning with the
brain so that was kind of the the the
hunch that that we saw there that
um i should say that the um
one of the early findings and one of the
early uh points that people who were
dubious about the finding that the
ventral streams align with
uh
imagenet trained resnets and and
alexnets and vgg nets
is that
people will say well well you're just
training the model to do a task you know
any sort of task will work uh it doesn't
matter whether it's object recognition
or whatever it's just turns out that
this is the test that you have data on
but this is a very uh
this is a very good like counter example
of that because you train
a model on a task which involves you
know 3d data
video spatial temporal data and yet
that uh model is actually the the model
that you that you train is really good
for that one task but is really terrible
at this task of aligning uh with the
brain
so that motivates us to look more deeply
into uh you know what else could the
could the
like if we don't train a uh if we don't
take you know pre-trained models to
solve this problem like what what could
we do and we know that uh a lot of the
dorsal visual stream is really cares
about navigation
so if you look at an area like mst
um
have you ever had vertigo
um sure
yeah so vertigo is like kind of sorry
this is like a weird non-secondary but
um
vertigo is kind of a funny thing right
because it's a inner ear problem right
so you have your vestibule and it kind
of it basically tells you there's
acceleration and ways that there
shouldn't be acceleration and that gives
you an impression of being dizzy
but also gives you like these weird
visual effects
yeah right which is uh uh which is
strange or you know if you drink a
little too much you might have that that
same kind of feeling
so there's an area in the brain which is
called mst which has these neurons which
receive both visual input and vestibular
input and the way that they receive
visual input is they have a lot of
selectivity for things like rotation and
expansion
and uh in wide field translation and so
we think that they're really involved in
navigation so if you're going forward
in a in a line
you have these neurons which receive
both the vestibular inputs so they know
how you're accelerating and where
gravity is and they receive all this
white field optic flow which is tells
you uh where you're
where you're heading so we said why
don't we train a deep neural network to
solve a navigation test so that the
network can uh can orient itself uh in
space essentially
so um so i used a uh an environment
uh which is um
[Music]
uh it's an environment for a drone
simulation it's called airsim and uh
it's really fun uh so it's an unreal
engine
uh and you can
you can uh basically fly a drone in
these suburban environments
and uh back out these sequences of
videos and then you can train a
a convolutional neural net uh 3d resnet
to solve the problem of figuring out
what is the
from a little sequence of uh
of movement
uh what is
uh the trajectory basically that's going
on like where are you heading are you
rotating are you going forward each
other etc
and so if you train a network on that it
turns out that if you visualize the the
the cells inside of the uh the train
network they really really look like
what you would see in the visual cortex
um so as a neurophysiologist or as like
an amateur neurophysiologist or a person
that's been in the vicinity of
neurophysiologists i was really i was
really stoked to see this so you see
these cells that are selective for for
translation and
um
translation but they don't care about
the pattern that underlies the
translation
and in particular you see these cells
like the one that you're that you're
visualizing here that like things like
spirals uh and some of the higher level
layers of uh of this network which was
um which was super exciting because
those look a lot like what you would see
in them so that yeah so basically the
networks that try to just predict
anything from a video that contains
motion weren't aren't like turns out
these neural net sorry the deep networks
uh i have to stop saying neural networks
here because it's ambiguous
um that that train on v any kind of
video data they're not super well
aligned with the brain however as soon
as you as you go maybe to like some sort
of an ego perspective right and you
especially you predict
your own parameters of motion so from
the from the visuals you're trying to
predict okay i went to the left i went
to the right i turned around uh from the
visual information and that turns out to
align very well with the brain data does
that make
like just maybe an esoteric question but
does that say anything about the need
for ai to be embodied maybe
oh i love this question uh yes 100
yes we should uh we should completely
embody ai yeah
so i think that uh
one um
one big question that uh came up during
the review is that you know we claimed
originally this was uh unsupervised or
self-supervised yeah in the abstract and
then the reviewers came back and said
well it's not really unsupervised itself
supervised it's a supervised network
because you know you know what the
answer is you're just training in a in a
supervised fashion
my feeling is that it is uh
self-supervised in the sense of when you
embody this in an agent so when i'm when
i'm a baby
let's imagine that i'm a baby and i'm
walking around the world i have some
control over where i'm heading yeah
right so i can say like i'm going to
turn this way i'm going to get in that
way i'm going to move forward i'm going
to go get that cookie
i'm going to look at my parent
uh and so forth so i am an agent yep so
that means that i control
the emotion that comes into my eyes
uh because the vast majority of motion
that we see in the world comes from uh
from our self-motion and so i can
correlate my motor plans with
what i see in the world and that means
that uh it's a it's a much easier kind
of problem
to correlate these two things
than
uh to say i
here's found data yeah which is the the
case of imagenet and figure out
something to to to model with this yeah
exactly right yes you also have this
diagram here from young laca uh talking
about self-supervised learning and it
seems very much that it is i agree the
line is like gray in some places but it
seems like if you are an embodied agent
you always have those motion parameters
ready right so it's much more like i am
going to
darken out part of
part of what i already know and try to
predict that from it it seems it falls a
lot into this into this diagram right
here
yeah absolutely so i think it looks more
like the bottom part of this diagram
yeah that you see there where you have
these two things which are happening in
the present but one part is occluded and
the other part is visible
so you're doing multimodal masking in
other words right so you have the vision
but now you're trying to predict the
vestibular or you have the vestibular
and you're trying to predict the vision
and so if you look something like uh
clip would be i think like maybe the
most popular model that's of the same
kind of multimodal kind you can say well
clip is a supervised model because
you're trying to predict
you know in a way you're trying to
predict
um language from uh from vision
but it's really uh this this kind of
masking and it's a i think it's a more
general
approach to solving uh this this type of
problem so yeah i agree with you
embodied agents i'm 100 percent on board
they're they're definitely going to be
awesome and uh
and actually questions about you know
what do reinforcement learning agents
learn they learn like good self-motion
representations for instance when
they're when they have a visual task i
think like those are super interesting
like what do you need to put in there
uh in order to get that that effect yeah
that that concept of me in ais is not
yet
really come through so far um but i'm
also looking into like i'm i'm looking
forward to having more of ais who
understand the concept of
of me and to be embodied and and and
sort of to have self self-state and all
of this kind of stuff i think that will
bring us
forward so
here in the next paper you you tackle
not i mean um
this this paper you're describing it
tackles the question oh it's the same it
is actually it is actually i just saw i
just saw in my notes that is again one
of one of your papers yeah
it is the question
why are there even two different of
these visual streams in in the brain
like it maybe makes sense if we if we
sit down but also you find some actual
empirical evidence for why it might be
um
might be that we even have two streams
right
yeah yeah yeah absolutely so uh i think
that's a that's an interesting question
like why are there two things rather
than one or four things or eight things
rather than uh than an arbitrary uh
number so uh so shahab who's the first
author on this paper um
worked on um
looking at
what it would take to to recreate both
ventral and dorsal stream
and
i think the remarkable thing i found is
if you train a a network like a cpc
network so a contrastive predictive
coding network which is one form of
self-supervised learning
in which
you're trying to
essentially discriminate between
different futures um if you will so
you're trying to you look at the the
past uh like a certain window in the
past and then you're trying to
tell apart like the actual future
uh embed in some subspace versus an
alternative future
uh which is uh which is dreamt up
so uh if you try to do that
then you know it's already been shown
that you can find good representations
and
videos but what's very interesting is
that
then you can ask the question of what
happens as you add more and more
substreams inside of this of this
network so if you remember uh the
original alex net paper uh
so yeah
yeah it did have two streams so if you
remember like very uh it's it's like a
while ago but um
what happened is that they had like tiny
gpus back in the day
right and so they couldn't fit the whole
model on just on just one gpu so what
they decided arbitrarily is to split it
up into two parts especially at the uh
at the early point
and then basically they so they were
independent but they could
re-communicate a little bit later on
um so which was
a pretty unique feature uh
back then people didn't really do that
uh but now it's it's quite common to you
know chop up the channels in different
ways and all sorts of things
um but what they found is that there's
this this uh this this very interesting
self organization principle where
all this all the uh the the filters on
one gpu turned out to be color selective
and all the filters on the other gpu
turned out to be
uh to be black and white which is whoa
that's weird just just by the fact of of
splitting up because the two streams
they don't always communicate right they
only communicate at very sparse
intermediate points
so so just this structural prior
gives rise to something that very much
looks like the brain in that in the
sense that one of the streams correlates
well with the ventral brain stream and
one correlates well with the dorsal
brain stream
yeah so in that in that case in the
early allynx that paper actually both uh
of the types of filters are different
subtypes that you see in uh in v1 but
they are you know functionally different
and they have different roles but it was
like kind of an interesting proof of
concept that if you just set a
separation arbitrary separation down the
middle you don't say anything else like
you don't say like you have to respond
to color you have to respond to this but
just you set a separation
it self organizes to something that's
interesting it's crazy and um
yeah it's it's weird so they might have
just increased themselves into like
building a better model by by having two
small gpus
yeah exactly so uh you know they say
that the necessity is the mother of
invention so i think this is a
particular case where
you know the limitations at the time
caused them to stumble onto something
which i think is is really deep and
interesting
which is symmetry breaking
so i guess ultimately you know when you
start with okay you could imagine that
if you
uh
just set all the weight parameters to
zero and then you perform your gradient
descent these two filter sets will learn
exactly the same thing or they'll crash
and burn
but by
adding a little noise right by
initializing your your network you're
pushing the network very very slightly
out of equilibrium and that's enough to
self-organize into this thing
and so shahab found a very similar
phenomenon in the context of these
networks which are trained in an
unsupervised manner in cpc
and
so being trained on videos was able to
find
that
these
uh parts of the one part of the network
uh was
and so again
this is this is an instance of a network
that has kind of a firewall in between
the two sets of filters and so he was
able to find that
these two um
sub-branches one of them was dorsal-like
and the other one was ventral-like
and was able to correlate that with some
some data that we have in uh in
mouseware there's tons and tons of data
on what's the relative selectivity of
these different things and found some
some really nice correlations
so that means that you can
all you would need basically is a little
bit of
a nudge
right and uh so so which is this is a
great idea like maybe you just
initialize the network in a sli so that
like the two things are just very
slightly asymmetric
because one thing i should say is that
um
the uh the two networks don't always get
the same label right so if you train the
network twice
one time it's gonna be dorsal ventral
and sometimes it's gonna be ventral
dorsal
whereas the brain every time you train
it it's the same that we know so there
are some exactly it's all ventral is
ventral dorsal structure so there's some
like inbuilt asymmetry but it's a very
probably like a very small asymmetry
because if you train it with real data
uh
and then it will automatically you know
self-generate into this uh
and bloom into this particular activity
cool um
so very exciting this could be that the
brain can organize itself for something
that's uh that's useful just from this
could be used i i guess for i mean
people are already you know in
multi-head attention they do multi-head
right and that's kind of
similar in that they they clearly
separate different computation that
cannot interconnect and therefore that
that sort of
they're also like the random
initialization probably does some
symmetry breaking and then you find that
the different heads respond to different
things people have investigated that
it's probably very much along the same
lines so i want to skip ahead a little
bit here to um the
concept cells
uh the
the is it this paper oh that's this is
why i think like uh i i think that
there's been a lot of movement in the
subfield and by the way i want to tell
your viewers because i know a lot of you
yours are coming from a machine learning
background versus a neuroscience
background and uh you know it's hard to
get into europe's but i think if you
know it's such a wide open field to in
neuroscience um there's so many
questions that if you care a lot about
representation learning
you know it's it's a pretty easy field
to jump onto
and uh and have positive reception so
um there's there's still a bunch of uh a
bunch of questions so grab your nearest
neuroscientist and go write a paper uh
encourage everybody to do it
definitely how to how to hack how to
hack
publications
there you go
um
yeah there you go so uh yeah so a clip
uh clip is
clip is weird
so if there's one thing that i would say
is when we saw
when we saw the results of of clip and
some of the
in terms of
of
how good it is and also the uh
inner visualizations that that chrysol
and gang uh worked on chelsea voss
um as well
um
i think that we were all kind of
surprised because they do look a lot
like the kinds of concept cells that you
see on the hippocampus right so the very
very very very famous paper uh
that did this uh is the
uh had the uh infamous jennifer aniston
cell
so i don't know if you're
in you're only in the context of your
article so it's one one cell that
responds to both what pictures and the
name and
various aspects of a person not not just
like exactly exactly so if i remember
correctly this uh this paper so they had
um they had people with intractable
epilepsy so these are human
patients and they were doing pro
recordings in the hippocampus to figure
out what was the
um the nature of their epilepsy and how
they could be treated
and
you know they spent a lot of time in the
hospital just being bored um and so
sometimes they enroll in two
experiments and these experiments tell
us more about the human brain than uh is
otherwise possible and so very thankful
for for these people that do this
um and uh so in this particular instance
they uh they presented different kinds
of uh of concepts and images and one of
the cells that they found had this like
amazing property that if you just show
the words jennifer aniston it would
respond if you showed the face of
jennifer aniston it would respond if you
showed
uh
i i like i i they didn't do like other
kinds of controls but i imagined that uh
if they had played dan and then you know
that the start of the of the french show
it probably would have
responded because it all came with this
like general uh concept of
of jennifer aniston
um so
ever since then uh people have been like
fascinated by this idea although it's a
much older idea you know this idea that
you have like a cell in your hippocampus
that responds to your grandmother it's
the grandmother cell idea
but um
one thing that was very interesting when
we first saw clip is that you have cells
can respond both to text and to
um
to images and in fact you can do these
new kinds of of adversarial attacks in
which you just
write the wrong
write the wrong text and it fools the
system into actually reading the text
and mislabeling
the uh the images
um so it sounds very hypocampus-like to
me and so in this particular paper they
uh they actually looked at um at this
problem and found that out of all the
different models that uh that they could
look
um
they they they found that the clip could
explain uh the most uh hippocampal data
which is super exciting i'm sure that
people are really going to
drill down further into this uh into
this finding yeah
but it's clipped specifically because
there's a lot of other unsupervised
models and somehow clip is the best and
we still don't understand why this is i
mean it's like the delta between it and
the the second best model is yeah it's
huge
but why
uh i i think no one knows right now and
um
and actually clipped the the just the
the the visual aspects of clip are also
very good at explaining some of the uh
um some um
some other data um so it's it's very
interesting to think about
what happens in a multimodal
fashion like what what happens when you
know experimentalists and
neurophysiologists like really like to
isolate one thing to just look at one
thing at a time but now you're talking
about something that can do different
kinds of modalities and i think that uh
you know multimodal
areas are going to be
some of the next things that are really
attacked by
uh unsupervised and so i mean it's also
a question i mean clip is huge it also
has a huge amount of data we don't
exactly know what data went into there
right there's a lot to
untangle here but the multimodality i
also feel that that is is a big part of
what's going to bring us forward in ai
and probably also you know since the
brain is always multimodal like i don't
you don't get like a stimulus that is
maybe not with computers you do but you
know just growing up in nature you
probably get zero stimuli that are just
unimodal right so
you're always in this mode of multi
modality
yeah and uh and one thing that's uh
that's interesting in particular for
babies you know if uh if you ever
interacted with babies they really like
to have toys which make lots of noise
which drives parents crazy
and but i think that there's a reason
for that right like why would you want a
like a toy that makes like a lot of
noise because clearly there's a lot of
pressure on making the noise as silent
as possible because the parents are just
like trying to sleep
um but i think that the kids just prefer
that because it's a multimodal stimuli
and you can do all sorts of causal
inference about what happens when i hit
this thing with this thing
so this is the the last um paper that i
i i want to look at maybe maybe you have
more but this is is challenges
the manifold perspective of deep
learning in in
your you you've described it a little
bit in the paragraph you say challenges
the manifold perspective and it favors
the causal perspective so what is meant
here and and what does this paper tell
us
oh yeah so
you remember we were discussing earlier
the mechanics of how you compare a brain
area and a deep neural network
and
so you could have
so i think a lot of uh deep learning
methods are rotation and variance so if
you take something like clip for
instance you're learning
um
i guess like this um this subspace which
is i guess like 128 dimensional uh in
the both from the visual side and from
the text side and you're trying to align
it in this 128 dimensional space if you
multiply the two by rotation matrix and
then the entire 128 dimensional space
gets gets rotated it's the same network
right it really doesn't matter whether
it's um
whether it's rotated or not what matters
just the locations on the manifolds and
so if you're thinking about aligning a
brain area and uh a neural network with
a
with a regression again the rotation
doesn't matter uh you're saying any any
weight matrix is just as good as any
other weight matrix
so that's the uh so so that's the
underlying
uh i think uh assumption and i think
that there's been a lot of of work
recently in neuroscience
focusing on this idea that you know
single neurons like don't really matter
what matters is the latent subspace in
which the near the the neurons are
responding so if you have a population
of a hundred thousand neurons
maybe they yeah it's a hundred thousand
neurons but if you present a bunch of
stimuli you find out that actually the
latent sub and you do like an svd on the
matrix of responses you find that the
latent subspace is actually just
five-dimensional or whatever
um so
first of all they're just random
projections from this five-dimensional
subspace
and
the and the the large dimensional
subspace doesn't really matter
so this paper um so
sorry and um it's been a lot of work in
in neuroscience showing that this is the
case especially in
in motor cortex uh so you know you have
tons and tons of neurons in your motor
cortex as you're going for uh for reach
movement and yet it seems that these
neurons really live in a very low
dimensional subspace
so that's what we call the manifold
theory
of uh
neuroscience uh it's that idea that the
neurons are in a high dimensional
subspace but they're just project random
projections of some lower dimensional
subspace
but one of the consequences that if it's
random projections then each of the
neurons individually should just be
you know weird
uh it should
you know respond to a bunch of different
things it shouldn't you shouldn't be
able to place a label because you could
like
so you you could rotate the entire space
it would still make sense right so
there's no there's no reason why an
individual neuron should align with just
like one axis in
in
that particular subspace
yeah exactly
um so
but neuroscientists really like
labeled axes
that's that's one thing that
uh that they're very fond of um so you
know you can imagine that you have like
an axis i don't know if you're in in
unity or unreal you know you have like
my avatar and then you just like hit
like one switch and i just go dude
you know just uh it just changes my
smile from from upwards to downwards
and um
oh sorry i
uh my
printer is haunted
and
so i'm just gonna disconnect it uh if
you don't mind because it makes the
lights flash
uh unfortunately
okay
i find it weird that printers are like
the oldest technology on the planet yet
still they're like the most troubled
like we should we should have figured
this out by now but we have not
yeah it's uh it's too bad so i still
print out papers because there's been
research that shows that you retain more
when you print something out rather when
you read it in the
um on a printed document rather than
yeah reading it on the but it's just
becoming so
so inconvenient that i think i'm going
to have to advance soon
okay so
starting back then and uh i apologize
where do you want me to restart
so um
we
yeah there's no there's no particular
reason why any
single neuron right should align with
any axes
yet people find that they do yes yes
exactly and that might be because uh you
know neuroscientists like the name
things and if something is not nameable
they'll say it's mixed selectivity or
whatever and then they'll just forget
about it
that's also a very good assumption
so both of these things could be
happening at the same time
but in this paper they found that
if you train a better vae which is a vae
which has a stronger
weight on on one of the kl terms
um
it tends to find disentangled
representations right so that the axis
actually matter so one axis is like my
smile the other axis is
uh
how much of a unibrow i have and you
know a third axis is you know what's up
with my mustache and etc etc
um and so they found that that aligns
pretty well with some uh neurons in
one phase selective area of uh infra
temporal cortex
and so uh they did some um some trickery
trying to do like one-on-one alignment
versus ensemble alignment and it looks
like you know the good interpretation
for this data
is that it's um
it's it's more of like a one-on-one uh
alignment
and yeah so so that could be a pretty
interesting but i i do want to point out
that there are certainly
um
uh distributed representations in the
brain it doesn't it doesn't mean that
because in this one area
you have uh non-distributed
representations
that that's the case for the whole brain
and it might be because of energetic
reasons
that we have this representation in this
in this brain area
because you know you want to have
how the what the distribution of
responses is over a stimulus ensemble is
very important uh for how efficient uh
the code is because remember neurons are
super noisy
right
so you want them you want to have like a
nice exponential distribution of of
responses
uh in order to have an efficient code um
given that you have this poisson like
noise
yeah in the data
so yeah um and
you you you say it it favors the
causal hypothesis it so it means that
maybe what's happening is that rather
than some simply encoding the signal
that you see that the brain is actually
building like a causal model of what's
happening like you know there are eyes
and there are eyebrows and that you know
the
the result of there being eyebrows is
that they look a certain way yeah and
then it would make sense again that they
are encoded like the structural priors
encoded in one space and then simply the
manifestation of that is the picture we
see
yeah yeah yeah maybe i misused the uh
the term causal here uh yeah i don't
want to mistake it for causal inference
and uh sure
yeah
um but i think that what i mean uh by
this is uh is a forward model for how
like one individual
so you can think of uh you can think of
a uh of a directed acyclic graph in
which
you know there's a bunch of different
factors one of them is whether or not i
wake up with a mustache today another
one is how close my eyes are another one
is
as my nose and these factors are you
know disentangled so that means that
um you know they're independent from uh
from each other and then i can just like
turn on and off the switch and generate
different different
uh
faces so that's uh i think like the
underlying naive model is the mr potato
head uh model
right in which you just like switch out
the different uh the different
components
uh and of course there are specific you
know holes that you can put the uh
the different the different things in
um so i think uh that
i i guess like the question is like are
these factors in this uh this factor
graph are they
like can you put labels on them and they
correspond to one thing that we would
identify as something that is
independently changeable so for instance
like we understand that age and lighting
for instance like those are two totally
disentangled uh things that have nothing
to do with each other
um
so
so the question is are they are they
different factors or are you rotated
like one is square root of two like one
over square root of two times age minus
one over square root of two times uh
lighting and so on and so forth and it
looks like they're really aligned
towards
um
towards the
factors that we can label
and that are indeed independent
both in brains and in this particular
model do you think that it plays a big
part that it because face like say
facial structure is it is something that
is truly let's say the individual
factors are actually independent because
of you know genetic variation uh allele
crossing during during meiosis sorry or
recombination and so on these things
actually
go in a fairly let's say this
uncorrelated uniform distribution in the
human population so almost every
combination of narrow eyes wide eyes you
know big mouth small mouth and so on is
possible and therefore it might make
just sense to let's say encode the
individual factors as individual neurons
as you say maybe for energetic reasons
um i think that that's that's a really
interesting hypothesis
but i don't think that that's uh that
that's the case i think that there might
be like a general you know algorithm
that makes it that tries to disentangle
these things uh into
into different uh
into different sub factors and then as a
consequence there's this natural
alignment with this other process
but
and of course if it's the case that
the
kind of latent model that is inside the
brain is better aligned with the latent
model that's in reality well that's
better
you know you want the uh the thing to
reflect but i don't think it's a hundred
percent
uh true that
um that these factors are really
uh
disentangled in in reality so for
instance uh
you know i i
i like a unibrow versus uh mustache like
these two things are probably
pretty correlated with yeah with each
other
uh
right
yeah yeah i see what i see what you mean
yeah
so
um we're we're we've been we've been
going through this a little bit there's
all i mean there's a lot of there's
other papers which which are definitely
also interesting like that
yeah i i really love this one
interesting is there yeah is there one
that you wanted to touch on particularly
well i wanted to give uh for you know
readers
that are coming slightly outside of this
field yeah i'm moving into this like
very rapidly moving feel kind of an
overview of what are the questions that
people are interested in like what are
kind of the some
of the interesting approaches that
people
are using uh to
um to tackle these and also encourage
people to come in our field and and uh
and and
you know get papers in and uh
and scoop us basically
um
so i really want to encourage people to
uh
to get into that i think um
i think that we've covered some of the
papers that uh i think are the most
interesting uh and uh
we'll see in the uh i actually wanted to
do a follow-up on precisely the kind of
agent-based representations uh that are
coming because that that is coming down
the line and i think that's going to be
super interesting
uh for this field so maybe we can end
with like some things to look forward to
uh in the future sure um so uh one of
the things that i think is gonna be
interesting for uh for the future is
like really taking evolution seriously
so we saw the uh uh actually maybe if
you can scroll to
where i show
um jess's just thompson's um
diagram of the different types of um of
models and and how they all feel
together that's at the very start it's
at the intro
um so just is a really nice way i think
of uh of uh explaining this
um which is that you know there's some
models which can really perform a task
and you know once we got to imagenet2012
like that was
that was where we we got there and then
you know in 2014
we really got into this accounts for
neural activity uh part of uh so
you know we can find models that can
both perform a task which is
biologically relevant and accounts for
neural activity and i think this year
was a big year for biological
plausibility and i don't want to say
this is the last word because clearly
there's way more work to be uh doing
there
you're going to have models which have
um realistic uh
biologically realistic kinds of gradient
descent or replace gradient descent with
something that's more biologically
plausible you're gonna have dale's law
you know so excitatory neurons
only make a connection only makes
excitatory connections and inhibitory
neurons only make inhibitory connections
and you'll have normalization and you
have temporal dynamics and so on and so
forth so that's like
the next five years is it's probably
just going to be to fill in this
biologically plausible but there's also
could have evolved i think that that's
that's like a super interesting uh
unknown questions and um
people are gonna start to
think about this problem in a serious
fashion and i want to point out uh
there's this uh there's this recent
paper that i
don't talk about here which uh from um
which is about evolving different kinds
of agents that can solve uh different
kinds of reinforcement learning tests
that actually has a
uh an interesting
evolution uh component to it yeah so i
think we're gonna start to see
and and we can actually like see the
process by which the brain can bootstrap
itself into existence which i think is
going to teach us something
about what it is to be human and i'm
sure there'll be ted talks and books and
and so forth but that's going to take
like another 5-10 years
um
another thing that i'm excited uh to
look at in the in the future is uh uh i
just wrote in my notes here hands
hands are great uh
i um
i i think that uh uh one uh one thing
that we uh
that we haven't like really taken
seriously so far
is the role of weak supervision
uh from a parental perspective but if
you think of like a a parent and their
baby they're going to point at things
they're going to say this is this this
is that and
you know it has had like hands have had
a huge role in our evolution as as homo
sapiens um and it's even like thought
that um
sign language
preceded the appearance of a voiced
speech
so that we probably have somewhere in
our noggins uh some areas which are
highly selective for hand gestures and
which are used for a kind of weak
supervision
that's important for um
for parents so
understanding what happens with that
personal space
and what what happens as uh
um as we use tools uh is clearly
important from like just that curiosity
of how
uh you know we went from uh australia to
get petacus to uh to modern humans and i
think it's gonna teach us a lot about um
yeah what it means to be human
awesome um last question from my side
with you're clearly interested in how
the brain works right and and see in
seeing you know can we can we make
parallels between ai models like deep
models and and brain areas and so on do
you think
that it is a necessity that we sort of
feed back the knowledge into the deep
learning realm so should we should we
put more effort into saying how does the
brain work okay let's do that because at
least that's that's like one example of
where intelligence was achieved
or do you think that you know how the
brain works is just like a happenstance
of nature and evolution and energy
restrictions and
you know it's not it's not super like
let's just do ai
you know the way it works best or option
three is something like
what however we build ai if we solve the
task it will automatically align with
the brain because there's like only one
real way to solve the task like in which
in which of these let's say camps or do
you find yourself in
yeah uh that's uh that's super
interesting um
and uh i i want to say that so people
have made for a long time that claim
that if we just study the brain we'll be
able to make better machines
so that that comes about and again and
again and uh i do want to point out that
this actually did happen uh as we saw
with convolutional neural networks
uh and the whole story of eubal and
weasel and the neocognitron and young
lacun and
and eventually imagenet 2012.
but you know it's really only happened
a few times it's not clear how much more
we have to
uh
like how much how many more instances of
this will happen um that's certainly the
view from from some people at a deepmind
for instance
uh that have really like gone into
cognitive neuroscience and have started
to do their own
fmri experiments to really you know
tackle these problems i think it's
really really interesting but i'm not i
think that it's going to teach us a lot
about the human brain
but not necessarily about how to make
intelligent machines because um we're
you know like these are different
systems as you point out and there are
certainly things about the brain which
are kludgy and and uh
and certainly sub-optimal
so how the retina is wired up is the
classic example it's wired up the wrong
way around octopuses have have it the
right way around and it doesn't seem to
bother them
so
uh that's a that's a clear example
um but maybe there's some thing that we
can
that we can identify with with brains
and that is going to unlock
the next generation of machine learning
maybe it's spiking neural networks for
instance you know people are
demonstrating like
yeah you could get something which is uh
like a thousand times or ten thousand
times more energy efficient if you just
used uh
these mixed signals spiking neural
networks so i i don't know
yeah and that would i mean a thousand
times ten thousand times that is sort of
the orders of magnitude you spoke about
before when it came to to date well
those are so here i'm thinking about uh
the energy efficiency uh so i think like
one recurrence
super comparable no i i think like uh
the uh the the one thing i i would point
out here is that if you look at all
these papers and you add up all of the
their uh their training time and carbon
emissions it's it's probably like pretty
substantial although i will say that you
know the the paper that um
that i'm the first author of here i
actually have the machine that i train
uh this thing on like right here
and uh
it's it's still like it's still a one
gpu machine so again i encourage your uh
your your viewers to uh to get into this
because you can still do things with one
gtx 1080. that's awesome
um but i think one thing that's that's
going to be really interesting is that
by studying you know better machines
we'll be able to start to understand how
to bring this back from the side of
machine learning and bring it back into
human health so that's very interesting
and and it's by and wide uh hasn't been
uh explored thus far but that i i'm kind
of a fan of the opposite direction that
most people are are really going into
so i i hope that that answers your
question i i don't think that naturally
if you just train on your own network to
solve a task it's going to do it the
same way that the brain does because
i don't think that that's that's really
pointed out i don't think that gpt3 does
things the same way that
a human does in any sort of meaningful
way no way
[Laughter]
even though they're both very good at
language
yeah
maybe gpt4
well if you ask gary marcus he'll say
that there's no way it'll never happen
never
neurosymbolic ai all the way yeah
all right cool yeah um for every to
everyone uh follow patrick uh many he's
me he's written papers lots of papers
you're also the cto of neuromatch
academy is that correct uh so i uh so i
helped neuromatch start actually so i'm
no longer cto there but uh it's a great
occasion for um for people that want to
learn more about that intersection
between neuroscience
and artificial intelligence
to
to bring that about so when we started
this a couple of years ago we just
figured oh we'll
do a few video lectures and present that
online and it was at the start of the
pandemic and people were bored so uh the
response was
out of this world uh so we had over 2000
applications and people from all over
the world wanted to learn more about
both
neuroscience and artificial intelligence
and
their intersection
so we ended up having i think 1700
students in the first cohort and having
200 tas and so it became a big thing
very fast
so i'm very happy that i helped bring
that about it was definitely
one of the most stressful times in my
life but
we could bring together people from very
disparate uh
backgrounds uh whether it's
people in emerging economies that are at
local universities there and people from
uh from ivy league universities in the
us canada and uh and the uk
together and working with the same
curriculum and under the same
circumstances so which was very cool and
then uh last year we did the same but uh
doubled in uh in size as well so i hope
that we'll be able to uh
to double this year
i'm sure the announcement actually for
um for the next uh version of uh
neuromatch academy will happen pretty
soon
okay so uh if you have people in the in
in your
audience that are interested in that i
highly
recommend to them to to do that it's a
great occasion to learn and we already
have um you know materials from last
year online so if you want to get
started on your learning uh you can do
that today
excellent
cool well patrick it was wonderful
wonderful having you here this is a new
world to me and i think for to a lot of
people listening right here so uh thank
you so much
and i hope to see you again with with
next year's review
awesome